y hoy en La Crónica de salud vamos a
tratar un tema bastante importante que
en este momento es pionero en España
pero que se puede replicar en otras
partes del mundo más Romero sala
bienvenida y buen lunes para usted
bienvenida tú también María Clara Bueno
hablemos de esta sentencia que emitió un
juzgado español y que le permitiría
tener más poder a las madres sobre todo
al momento del parto si es una una
sentencia como decías en primera
instancia que ha sucedido en gran
canaria y falla como decías a favor de
una madre que demandó al hospital porque
estuvo 17 horas en trabajo de parto
tratando un parto natural un parto
vaginal de dos gemelos antes de que le
practicaran una necesaria y de hecho
haber esperado tanto tiempo hizo que una
de sus dos hijas tuviera un problema de
oxígeno que provocó una discapacidad
permanente a partir de ahí no nace la
demanda la sentencia pero más allá de
este caso particular las sentencias que
tienen esta posibilidad de sentar
jurisprudencia Es decir que a partir de
ahora y a otros tribunales que se basen
en esta sentencia para emitir dictámenes
parecidos lo que es muy importante es
que el texto reconoce el derecho
fundamental de la persona embarazada a
elegir entre un parto natural o la
cesárea no y considera que lo que le
sucedió a la demandante es un caso de
violencia obstétrica porque no tuvo de
acceso digamos a toda la información
alrededor de la información de su
situación del embarazo las opciones que
tenía o sus ventajas y desventajas no
también la sentencia dice que hay una
concepción patriarcal de la mujer que no
tiene en cuenta su poder de
autodeterminación sobre su propio Cuerpo
sin embargo la sociedad española de
ginecología y obstetricia no está tan de
acuerdo con esta sentencia y ya se ha
pronunciado en contra escuchemos
estamos en total desacuerdo con dichas
sentencias y se basa en que no se ha
respetado el plan de parto de la
paciente los obstetras tienen que actuar
siempre basándose en las guías de
asistencia práctica de esta sociedad y
no las preferencias de la paciente que
sí serán tenidas en cuenta en la medida
que sea posible a pesar de este rechazo
mar hay un término que es fundamental
para entender aquí y es la violencia
obstétrica en qué consiste si es un
término que se define por toda esa
violencia basada en género por el hecho
de ser mujeres que sucede durante el
embarazo durante el parto o durante el
postparto y es un debate muy abierto en
los últimos años no en este caso los
médicos defienden que no aplicaría que
los médicos siempre por seguridad de los
pacientes toman sus decisiones y que al
finales del especialista no quien tiene
toda la información para tomar
decisiones que velen por la seguridad y
por la vida de la persona embarazada y
de sus PPS de sus bebés y que respetar
las preferencias
no siempre puede tener los resultados
esperados No que al final quizás las
madres o personas gestantes no tienen
toda esa información sin embargo cuando
hablamos de esto siempre tenemos que
tener en cuenta que en una situación de
atención médica donde hay un
especialista y un paciente hay una
situación estructural de desigualdad
especialmente en un momento tan
vulnerable como es por ejemplo el parto
o el embarazo en los casos de una mujer
y que también durante años y décadas
quienes han practicado quienes han
desarrollado ciencia son los hombres y
también la investigación científica o la
atención sobre el cuerpo de las mujeres
ha tenido esos sesgos pero para
aterrizar un poco todo este debate
buscamos unas cifras recogidas por la
organización Panamericana de la salud en
Chile porque no hay muchos datos a gran
escala que evaluaban más de 2.000
mujeres como se habían sentido en el
momento de la atención en el parto y
valoraban en la escala del 1 al 5 alguna
serie de situaciones no por ejemplo
vemos que le daban un 3,5 es decir
varias habían valorado que se habían
sentido mal en sentirse infantilizadas o
anuladas por el equipo médico como si
fueran incapaz de tomar decisiones
también había valoración relativamente
alta es decir más de la mitad en esa
escala entre el 1 y el 5 que les fueron
imposibles o muy difícil manifestar
inquietudes miedos o hacer preguntas y
también que Se realizaron procedimientos
médicos sin consentimientos ni
explicación es decir Estos ambientes son
una realidad Que pues nos hacen pensar
que no siempre es tan fácil que la
comunicación fluya y se pueda tomar una
decisión consensuada al final entre
médicos y pacientes que sería sería lo
ideal y ante la falta de consenso muchas
veces son los médicos quienes deciden
cuando por ejemplo realizar la cesárea
según su propia agenda en vez de las
necesidades de las madres exacto y al
final ahí para mí lo más importante es
la escucha no la capacidad de saber que
la persona embarazada también es quien
sabe mucho y conoce su propio cuerpo y
que los especialistas pues pueden opinar
también pero respetando ojalá las dos
partes pasamos a una noticia de Estados
Unidos porque las autoridades levantaron
un veto que venía de decenas de años
atrás
y es la prohibición para los hombres
gays y bisexuales de donar sangre Si así
es lo vamos a celebrar al final es una
noticia que pues
tumba una discriminación más que Todavía
existe la decisión él fue de la fda la
agencia de medicamentos de Estados
Unidos y publicó unos nuevos
lineamientos Aquí vemos el comunicado
básicamente en el que dice que
la elegibilidad del donante se evaluará
según un cuestionario individual que
evalúe los riesgos pero que no tenga en
cuenta ni el género ni la orientación
sexual de estos donantes del
cuestionario será el mismo para todas
las personas hasta ahora los hombres que
tienen sexo con otros hombres debían
esperar al menos tres meses desde su
último encuentro sexual para poder donar
sangre es decir que todavía había una
última Barrera digamos que tenían que
saltar los lineamientos de ahora
aseguran que una persona no puede haber
tenido una pareja sexual nueva o
múltiples parejas sexuales en los
últimos tres meses que tampoco pueden
haber realizado prácticas como el sexo
anal en los últimos tres meses y que no
pueden donar sangre las personas que
estén medicamentos para tratar o para
prevenir el VIH Como por ejemplo la prep
o los antirretrovirales pero sin asumir
que estas prácticas son exclusivas de
los hombres gays o bisexuales o que
todos los hombres que tienen sexo con
hombres tienen estas prácticas que ahí
está un poco no la visión
discriminatoria sino que se centran al
final En qué Pues en qué medidas pueden
reducir el riesgo de transmisión de VIH
bueno es una medida entonces que era
discriminatoria no es así así es y de
hecho como tú bien decías que viene de
décadas atrás estas prácticas estas
medidas empezaron a aparecer en
muchísimos países sobre todo a partir de
la crisis de VIH en los años 70 y pues
todavía a día de hoy años después estas
comunidades tenían que someterse todavía
al estigma acarreado no a pesar de que
la situación haya cambiado tanto pero es
que además Estados Unidos no es la
excepción actualmente por suerte la
mayoría de países en América Latina y en
el continente americano permiten La
donación de sangre de hombres gays y
bisexuales pero por ejemplo en Venezuela
Sigue estando prohibido a día de hoy y
además en la mayoría de estos países
donde está permitido ha sido una una
nueva medida adoptada muy recientemente
en Canadá el año pasado Estados Unidos
de este año Uruguay en 2020 Colombia
definitivamente el año pasado es decir
que es un avance reciente que por
supuesto vamos a celebrar pero no que no
vamos a olvidar que necesitamos todavía
seguir avanzando en este tipo de medidas
por ahora Gracias a ustedes por traernos
toda la información sobre estos avances
clínicos Gracias María Clara